[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
they're dead Beats
that's right
I don't want to pay the [ __ ] debt I
don't care about the country they don't
care about the economy
they don't care about your economic
stability they don't give a [ __ ] they're
Republicans
I mean of course they don't give a [ __ ]
about you they don't give a [ __ ] about
the country
they'll default on the debt what's the
difference what do they care what do
they care honestly the main thing that
they're trying to do here is not it's
not exactly default on the debt
I mean this is already
appropriated funds that have already
been allocated they have to pay the
executive branch has to write the check
for it
what they really want to do is take away
your Social Security and your Medicare
and your social safety net that you paid
for that's right it's not entitlements
you you [ __ ] vile bastards
we paid for those things Medicare Social
Security other social safety nets we pay
for those you [ __ ]
us the people the government we pay for
those it's our [ __ ] get your hands off
of it
that's what the Democrats should be
saying they should not negotiate with
terrorists [ __ ] them [ __ ] them you want
to have economic terrorism
and strip away
benefits that the American people paid
for that they relied on having there
when they needed it [ __ ] you do not
negotiate with them Democrats [ __ ] them
tell them to [ __ ] all the way off all
the way
all the way
you don't have to negotiate with them
anyways they're going to raise the debt
ceiling
this is again this is just a ploy to
strip away your Social Security benefits
you the people who are receiving them
right now not this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where they talk about oh well future
general I'm not talking about this
generation
uh we don't want to strip we don't want
to strip benefits that the American
people paid for from this generation we
just want to do it for future
Generations I got a video I want to show
you today of some [ __ ] scoundrel
talking about how people want to work
longer that's why we're gonna raise the
age of Social Security that's why we're
gonna raise your retirement age because
people I get people all the time giving
up to me telling me they want to work
longer there is nothing absolutely
nothing preventing people to work into
their 90s and and until they're dead for
that matter
they lived me 150 you can work as long
as you want to
that doesn't mean that we need to up the
statute of when the exact retirement age
is to receive the benefits you [ __ ]
paid for they're not entitlements I'm
sick of hearing this [ __ ]
I'm sick of this nonsense
I'm sick of it
that somehow Social Security Medicare
are [ __ ] entitlements they are not
entitlements we pay for them just look
at your goddamn paycheck
if you're self-employed go look at how
much self-employment tax you pay
it is all to fleece your [ __ ]
benefits that you paid for to make sure
that they give tax cuts to their [ __ ]
donors that's all it is that's all this
is
redistribution of wealth that's what
they want and they want the wealthy to
have it all
that's what they want
they don't give a [ __ ] about the economy
they don't give a [ __ ] about you they
don't give a [ __ ] about our credit
rating
they don't give a [ __ ] about our
national security they don't give a [ __ ]
about our stability they don't give a
[ __ ]
never have never will their [ __ ]
domestic terrorists they call themselves
that speaking of domestic terrorists
apparently
there's a former America First Nazi
who was a republican candidate down in
New Mexico lost by 3 500 votes in a
house district got his ass stumped
he's an insurrectionist by the way yeah
he was there on January 6th he was there
he's got pictures that he's posted on
social media to prove it of course
of course this [ __ ] bonehead is a
self-proclaimed terrorist
and him and people he hired went and
shot up buildings
and his opponent's house damn near damn
near having bullets strike her
ten-year-old daughter
now I posted I saw a video this morning
it's going around Twitter right now
of a little three or four-year-old boy
being groomed by his domestic terrorist
father teaching him how to kill humans
and we wonder why and we stand around
we're standing around like what the hell
do we have a problem with gun violence
in this country why in the [ __ ] do we
get do we got political candidates going
and trying to kill their opponents he
won by 3 500 votes votes why do we have
this what could it possibly be their
[ __ ] American Taliban
they're mind [ __ ] they're deluded
they're a cult and it's a gun cult
and they want to commit political
violence
and they're training the Hitler Youth
right now to do it
that's why they call you groomers that's
why they call liberals groomers because
they have to deflect
when I was a child
in rule America
we had guns
we hunted with them
my grandpa my uncles my dad hunted with
guns they didn't hunt humans
never never in my childhood never in my
childhood ever being around guns or
watching someone around guns did I ever
ever see an adult
train a little child to kill human
beings
foreign
terrorist problem in this country
they're in the living room in this video
oh yeah well I'm going to show it to you
you've probably already seen this
[ __ ] stupid video
and they made it it ain't like someone
observed this happening they're proud of
it
just like Lauren bobert Thomas Massey
are proud that they're American Taliban
they're [ __ ] domestic terrorists
I can't even believe that this story in
New Mexico Pena is his name
who is a losing candidate in the house
race in New Mexico of America First Nazi
an insurrectionist a treasonous piece of
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] this isn't the headline
story The lead-in
of course the Republicans don't want to
talk about this they're not going to
just like Kevin McCarthy doesn't want to
talk about how George Santos is a
goddamn fraud
of course again you know my opinion on
George Santos leave that son of a [ __ ]
in
he's just a typical Republican he's not
an outlier
he just likes to outlaw them a lot
but they're going to ignore this story
just like they're going to ignore the
fact that the reason why they don't want
to raise the debt ceiling is to get
Democrats
to agree to cut the American people's
benefits that they paid for strip them
away from them and lower taxes for the
rich again that way their donors have
more money it's a redistribution of
wealth [ __ ]
and if you're not using that phrase
against these [ __ ] then you're
doing it wrong it's redistribution of
wealth
that's what they want with this debt
ceiling fight [ __ ] them tell them to
[ __ ] off
democrats should stand strong no matter
what happens don't lose your [ __ ] gut
it's time we fight for this democracy
in the arena of ideas
enough of this [ __ ] where we can't be
strong and we can't tell them to [ __ ]
off and we can't we can't make sure
that the American people know who's
gonna fight for them
who's gonna fight for them if Democrats
give in and let these son of a [ __ ]
take your safety net who
it's time we should start gerrymandering
districts now we should start planning
to Jerry Mandarin districts now right
now [ __ ] them
steal it away from them that's right I
said it
if you ain't cheating you ain't trying
because if you're gonna lose your
democracy you might as well [ __ ] lose
it going down in flames
and if you think that this debt ceiling
fight is the fight that's going to be
the worst fight
this year you're wrong
the fight to keep the government open
will be the biggest fight they're not
going to default on the debt
their donors don't want that to happen
they just want the fight they want to
see how much how many [ __ ] pennies
how many [ __ ] pennies they could
squeeze out of the American people to
redistribute it to the [ __ ] wealthy
that's what they [ __ ] want
to give a good God damn about no credit
rating
their donors do though ah they're
[ __ ] donors do
foreign but they'll go all the way to
the [ __ ] Edge all the way to the
moment
so democrats should just sit back and
let them [ __ ] fail
they're the party you know they're the
party of losers
let them [ __ ] lose [ __ ] them
they can't even pick a speaker let alone
organize to make sure
that they managed to to run up the clock
for the debt ceiling
[ __ ] them let them fail let them fail on
them
and then we could decide in 2024 rather
we want these cowards back or not
because that's what they are they're
weak [ __ ] cowards
Republicans the America First Nazi party
the party you know the party of frauds
the domestic terrorist
the American Taliban whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call them yalkaida whatever
you want to call them that's what they
are
I know most the people who listen to
this show
our pro-democracy they believe in it
they believe in the foundations of it
you know not every democracy is perfect
of course
we see it happening in Ukraine Ukraine's
not a perfect democracy
far from it
but even as imperfect as that democracy
and Sovereign Nation is it's worth
fighting for
because the simple idea the simple
principles
of democracy
will deliver equity and equality does it
take a long time you goddamn right I
don't know if you've been noticing
it takes a long time
they're resilient they absolutely are
not going to let go of their white
privilege anytime soon they're terrified
terrified
that if their privilege is lost
then they'll be treated the way they
want to treat the minority
that's right
the marginalized they're scared they'll
be treated that way the way they want to
treat the marginalized that's what
they're terrified of the most
listen if marginalized communities
wanted Revenge they'd already took it
you stupid [ __ ]
and that's what this fight is over
for the debt ceiling
is to strip away and redistribute
America's American people's money their
money that they paid
it's our social safety net it's ours we
paid for it just go look at your goddamn
check
your W-2
it's ours
enough of this [ __ ] delusional lies
this [ __ ]
that somehow somehow we're gonna be less
of a Nation because we agree to pay the
bills that we already allocated the
funds for
should have
hail some of these Appropriations came
because of republicans in Congress and
now they don't want to pay their bills
of course they're [ __ ] Deadbeats
of course they are but again
it's about stealing your money
it's about stealing what you paid to get
in benefits
they do this all around not just to not
just to every average American they do
this to veterans
they did they they do this to the
military
they do this in foreign aid
they do it all over the place
they love to redistribute wealth to the
wealthy to their donor class they love
it oh they [ __ ] love it
so stand strong with one message and and
one
one [ __ ] narrative
[ __ ] you
default on the dead [ __ ] do it do it I
dare you I [ __ ] dare you do it we're
not giving a goddamn inch not a [ __ ]
penny you can [ __ ] off
that's what the American people need to
do trust me
Democrats are gonna follow your
narrative and your messaging on this
we need to be the tail that Wags the dog
it's time it's time we Wag that
[ __ ]
and I'll be the spearhead I don't give a
damn
let's do it let's create a narrative in
messaging that forces forces these
Republicans to do their job govern
do your job [ __ ]
and if they know that the Democrats will
stand back and let them fail
they'll find a way oh they'll find a way
they'll find a way to bring it to the
floor trust me Democrats are going to
vote
to raise the debt ceiling it's going to
happen on the floor they're gonna get a
vote to raise the debt ceiling
it's just a matter of how much of our
money the American people's money are
they going to give away
to the rich donor class and take away
the benefits that we paid for
they're not entitlements I'm so sick of
hearing that garbage
I'm sick of it
and such [ __ ] they are not
entitlements they were not given to us
we worked we paid for those son of a
[ __ ]
and it's time we do it with one voice
one narrative One National message
and not let up
it's up to you I'm telling you I told
you that these fights were not be over
even if we did well in the 22 22
midterms and we did we did well the one
thing that we didn't do
was be able to out gerrymander them and
that's our next step that's our next
goal I'm telling you that's what we need
to do as liberals in this country we
need to gerrymandered the [ __ ] out of
these blue States [ __ ] them [ __ ] this
[ __ ] them it's enough of this garbage
you're either Gonna Save democracy or
you're going to lose it one or the other
so what are you gonna do you're going to
stomach up and do the things that you
don't want to do you goddamn right
it's time to fight
we can gerrymander the [ __ ] out of these
blue States gerrymander their
representation out of that state
California Illinois New York all of them
every [ __ ] one of them
Michigan Wisconsin take him and
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of them
gerrymander them into the into the
possibility that they couldn't even come
up with a majority in the House of
Representatives [ __ ] them they don't
know how to govern they don't know how
to do it they're not responsible and
they're domestic terrorists anyways all
they want to do is use our democracy to
destroy it
so we might as well use our democracy to
make sure they don't
it's time we stop sitting around holding
hands singing Kumbaya
they've awakened the sleeping giant
they totally underestimated and
liberalism and people who are
pro-democracy
and people who are for Liberty
are weak
they are [ __ ] mistaken
I watched the video I think it was on
Tick Tock or Instagram I don't know
I don't know where it was at Jesus
Christ hopefully I'll be able to find it
back I don't think I was able to save it
but I hope I can find it back
there was uh more Nazis literal Nazis
trying to stop
a drag show somewhere
and the entire Community came out and
shut them the [ __ ] up
stop them from stopping this show to
happen and frankly they just had a
bigger goddamn show
and at the end of the video
the man in the video said and you
thought you could out organize the gays
boy were you mistaken
we know how to organize folks
the lgbtq community the black community
women
we have all the power we have it it's
ours
all we have to do is use it
and it's our voices it's our messaging
it's our narrative
in one voice and One Direction
of pro-democracy we've got gen Z with us
they're with us they may not agree on
every single point but they're with us
with this pro-democracy stuff
and that demographic and that generation
is only getting older and more able to
vote
now
is the time
to lean in to democracy one cannot let
up
this fight over the debt ceiling let
them fail
and if they fail they fail punish them
and if they raise the debt ceiling they
did their job a bare minimum
and hold them accountable for for only
doing the bare minimum
we are the strength in this nation
liberalism is the strength of democracy
it is us we have to band together we
have to stay together we cannot we
cannot break
we cannot relent we have to stay focused
on democracy
they are trying to steal it away from
you just like they're trying to steal
the money that you paid in for your
safety net I am so glad that you are
here on a Tuesday January 17th
for two full hours as you are every
single weekday and as I am every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch
we're trying to get the 20 000 on
YouTube hit that subscribe button do me
a huge favor do me a huge favor this
month I only ask one thing of the
audience I mean other than coming and
listening of course
as you like to do
the only favor I ask is you subscribe to
the YouTube channel no matter where you
watch
and the other the most important part is
to share it with three people share it
with three people get those three people
to subscribe and start listening
even if they're your mother uncle or
your crazy Maga cousin or your Q Anon
ant
it's okay
share it get them to listen I'm telling
you
that's what I want get them here get
them to listen but subscribe to that
YouTube channel let's get to twenty
thousand two years of Tony in January of
2023 also you can follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod
and it would be nice if you downloaded
every single episode every one of them
he'll go re-listen to it I think what
I'm gonna do on the directories I've
been thinking a lot about this
about the the directories and how we
post the show on the directories for
those of you out there who listen to the
directories you know I do a 30 minute
rant every time it's called the a block
we're in the a block right now
and I think what I'm gonna do with the
directories and I want the audience's
input on this
because you guys are the ones who listen
on the directories Apple Spotify Google
the audio version of the show because we
record it live so I record it and then I
have to cut it and and then post it over
on the directories and publish it I
think what I might do is do a part one
part two type thing where part one is
the 30 minute rant it's the very first
30 minutes of the show
and then the part two is the second part
of the show it'll give a person an
opportunity to maybe watch one or the
other or maybe both tell me what you
think if the moderators out there can
kind of take a look at what people are
saying about that and uh jot down some
notes that would be great because we
have the best moderators in the world I
don't know if you know that you're the
greatest audience in the world and we
have the greatest moderators to go along
with it so give them love in the chat
they are here every day working hard
making sure
that our chat is clean you know we want
the hate Watchers yeah the moderators
know why I love the hate Watchers but we
want to keep it clean over there we
don't need any nonsense buffoonery
terrorism inside of the chat so everyone
make sure if you want to get to the live
chat subscribe to the YouTube channel
now just go to YouTube the Tony Michaels
podcast but the thing that you can do
most is go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the touch
down at the bottom of the screen right
there right there you see it scrolling
across the Tony michaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com all the links are
there
on the website you can also you can also
give us a tip if you want to give
monetary support that would be fantastic
too but this month my ask is this
subscribe to the YouTube channel if you
would please and also share it with
three other people and see if they'll
share with three other people you know
what I mean if you find someone
who's in this fight for democracy and is
sick and tired of these America First
Nazis trying to take away your [ __ ] that
you paid for and redistribute to their
wealthy [ __ ] donors like they're
trying to do by threatening to cut
Social Security Medicare
with the debt ceiling
invite him
they'll like it yeah sure and we'll
we'll get this National narrative this
National messaging going
make sure that we can say it with one
voice
um I'm gonna try to see if we can get a
guest on today you know it's Tuesday but
Texas Paul is on vacation I don't know
if he's paying attention to his social
media Texas Paul is on vacation so he
won't be joining us this Tuesday I think
a couple weeks he's on vacation
so Tuesdays right now are minus Texas
Paul but that's okay he'll be back he's
gonna be back don't worry don't worry
he's just taking a few weeks
taking a few weeks he's got an
anniversary I think that's going on so
he wants to have some fun he deserves a
vacation he deserves some time away as
we all do
so uh Texas Paul won't be joining us
today or the next I think next week
maybe the week after I don't remember I
don't recall the dates exactly off the
top of my head but it'll be a few weeks
before Texas Paul is back on Tuesdays
but he will be back he will be back he's
excited this is on Tuesdays is uh when
he called me he called me last week I
don't know it was a week before and he
said hey next week and what we're gonna
after next week we're gonna go on
vacation so next week will be the last
week for a couple weeks until we get
back
and um
he said this this is his favorite part
of his week is Tuesday is spending
Tuesday with the audience here and going
through the issues every single step of
the way getting that narrative getting
that messaging out to the people so the
people can spread the messaging because
you the audience are the key you're the
key to this it's you
it's you that have the power to go out
and make sure that the narrative is the
way it needs to be and stop anyone in
their tracks that do not have that
narrative and speaking of that I want to
talk about this document staying in a
conspiracy theory that's going around
about the Secret Service and I want you
I want people to shut the [ __ ] up about
this this is ridiculous you're actually
playing into manga's hands when you're
when you're spinning this conspiracy
theory about the Secret Service I'll
tell you about it when we come back so
don't go anywhere be right back
right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
[Music]
this documents thing the Secret Service
conspiracy theory planning documents
okay let me tell you why this is [ __ ]
dumb and you should not be saying this
[ __ ]
it plays into their hands it's stupid
number one it's not true it's it's it's
[ __ ] it's so far-fetched if you
believe that the Secret Service
is organized enough
to manage to work their way into the
Biden residence and plant classified
documents in a way that would that the
documents could be traced back with
custody uh to to an officer a skiff that
the vice president had and that was
packed up you are a [ __ ] bonehead
number one
and if anyone out there in the audience
is spending this conspiracy theory stop
you're you're you're hurting our
narrative you're hurting the story
here's why
it's not going to be true okay it's just
not
that's it's not even going to be close
to being the truth not even in the same
universe as being the truth
now if you continue and more and more
people start to pick up this stupid
[ __ ]
conspiracy theory that somehow they were
planted
and and somehow Joe Biden's being set up
you're going to lose grasp of your
narrative you're going to lose it and
the reason why is because they're gonna
point that [ __ ] out
they're gonna mock you for it
it's not gonna work well for our
narrative look
it is really simple on the documents
case where your focus and your narrative
needs to stay
it needs to stay on the intent and the
obstruction of Donald Trump who stole
our government documents
to cover up his coup attempt
okay it's very simple it's very easy
it's not going to be hard
for that to be smoked out and to be true
we already we already know we already
see the evidence before us
in the fact that Merrick Garland paired
the January 6 case and the documents
case under one special counsel
that's important that is very important
and more even more important that he
appointed us as different special
counsel for the Biden's documents if if
it was such if it was the same case
wouldn't you believe that Jack Smith
would be the one
concerned about the Biden documents it's
not because it's not the same it's not
the same case the case in Trump
and Mar-A-Lago is the January 6th
cover-up that's why he's obstructing
that was his intent that was his
criminal intent to steal those documents
and his Criminal Intent not to give them
back and possibly destroy them you don't
know that for sure yet but there was a
hell of a lot of empty folders reported
so stop talking about the Secret Service
and Joe Biden's house and by the way the
logs again this is the the other dumb
thing about this narrative this logs
there's no logs for Joe Biden's house
right so I say give them the logs
because there's not any there's no logs
there's not going to be logs for a
private residence so what the
Republicans continue to bark up these
stupid trees don't you bark up a stupid
tree
don't lose focus don't lose the
narrative don't lose the plot
the plot is that Donald Trump stole our
documents
to cover up his coup attempt
on January 6 because we know that's what
it is now and we know that it's tied to
domestic terrorism I don't know if
you've been following this story but
we're going to keep following it
was a losing a [ __ ] Republican loser
imagine that a [ __ ] Republican loser
in New Mexico he's a Q and honor
apparently he's a January 6th
insurrectionist
he's the likes of Ashley Babbitt
they're violent their domestic
terrorists they want to commit violence
he lost by 3 500 votes
and then him and four people he hired
went to try to shoot and kill people in
buildings
and Destroy property
now he was arrested in a raid yesterday
and apparently there were more people
arrested and were involved in this one
of the people that he hired
was indicted apparently on federal drug
and Firearms charges
this is who they are
when they said in Texas at CPAC and they
put it up on the Jumbotron and said we
are all domestic terrorists they [ __ ]
meant it
meant it
take them at their word
that's what they are
I can't believe that this story
isn't being spoken
by national reporters every five seconds
and you're not going to get a republican
anywhere to acknowledge this story oh
[ __ ] no who where what
New Mexico is that a state
is there house districts in New Mexico
they're not even going to acknowledge
the existence of it
and the reason why is because it backs
up the truth and the truth is is that
they are domestic terrorist Maga the
America First Nazi party they want
violence
and they want it now and they want
political violence that's what they want
they can't they can't win on ideas
they can the only way that they're that
they have control of the house is they
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of our states
and that's why elections matter
that's why elections matter the census
[ __ ] matters big time and our fight
to gerrymander our states matter we
should gerrymander the ever loving [ __ ]
out of them [ __ ] Fair [ __ ] fair you you
[ __ ] weak ass people out there that
think this politics is a fair fight get
the [ __ ] out of here and if you think
you're gonna win by playing Fair against
these people you are out of your mind
they will steal your democracy they will
stop on it they will piss on it and they
will [ __ ] on it they don't give a [ __ ]
so you better not give a [ __ ] when
you're fighting for it
it's important
it's important
oh Tony You Can't Fight Fire with Fire
watch us
you just hide and watch
again I'm telling you liberals in this
country that's where the strength comes
from of organizing
you think they can out organize us are
you serious
you think they can outmessage us
you think they can they you think they
can create a national narrative that's
better than ours [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's
where you start in defeatism
that's not what we're gonna do We're not
gonna be defeated
and we're not going to start from a
position of defeat [ __ ] no let them let
them default on the debt [ __ ] them do it
dare you do it
show how inept you are
show how worthless you are at governing
do it
just like the Democrats [ __ ] dare
them to vote 15 times
first Speaker of the House
until he had to sell every single point
of his peaker speakership away hell he's
not even the speaker at this point the
[ __ ] can't even stand there and
make sure that George Santos had does
not have his hands on any committees
until the Ethics Committee is done with
their stupid investigation which they
strip the Ethics Committee that was the
whole point that was the trade for
George Santos's vote for Kevin McCarthy
which by the way the only reason why
Kevin McCarthy won is because of George
Santos
the only disappointment that I have with
George Santos is why us as Democrats
aren't [ __ ] gerrymandering the [ __ ]
out of New York I mean the ever loving
[ __ ] out of it [ __ ] them gerrymander the
[ __ ] out of that state
we own that state they know we own that
state we have the power in that state
gerrymandering [ __ ] them take every
District away from maybe one give them
one District in New York why not just
one
just one
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of it
I'm sick of it and pack the courts pack
the [ __ ] courts as soon as we
get an opportunity as soon as we get an
opportunity we need to pack the courts
and we're packing them right now I mean
that thanks to you getting out there and
voting especially in Georgia thank you
very much but Georgians making the
correct decision of putting a sane
person as their senator
not some kind of fraud listen everyone's
oh George Santos is a fraud Herschel
Walker stood on stage and flashed a fake
badge and said he was a police officer
and you think George Santos is some kind
of outlier
I got a fake badge to give you it's
ridiculous
he is a republican that is who they are
their entire principle is fraud the
whole [ __ ] bit of it
well
it is what it is but let's go to some
video because I gotta show you some
video of course we have the new video
here on the Tony Michaels podcast so
let's round up the Tweety tweets and the
trendy trends for the shitless Roundup
start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
almost a new meaning to it as Twitter
gets worse and worse and worse oh my God
elon's Twitter and [ __ ] pile of [ __ ]
I'm dead serious holy [ __ ] man there's
an account on there and I I'm about to
just do something about this
there's a count on there and I I've
talked about this uh yesterday now with
Gabe Sanchez there's again on Twitter
that's they're pulling out videos that
are two years old and [ __ ] that have
nothing to do with coven nothing to do
with the vaccine and they're spinning
narrative around it as if the vaccine is
killing people and all kinds of crazy
ass stupid delusional [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
not even close to being the truth
just [ __ ] outright lies
um and it's pissing me off because it's
showing up in my timeline and Nick Adams
is showing up in my timeline oh my God
every single one of these vile gross
[ __ ] I don't know how it's
happening I don't know what but let me
tell you something
um this is why it is so important over
the next two years that we have a a
singular message
we cannot divert from a singular message
of pro-democracy in this country we have
to have the message and the narrative
down and we have to March forward with
it as a singular message
that is what will win us the house back
in 2024 secure the Senate and make sure
we have the presidency not only that we
have to win these State races I don't
know if you noticed but these states are
getting crazier and crazier in my state
of Missouri they they don't even they
they're so [ __ ] terrified of women
they don't even want their arms showing
what the [ __ ] are you serious
you are you are so you are so hopped up
in on a on a horn
that you see women's shoulders and it
makes you want to I don't I don't know
what these guys are doing
and I have no idea why why they think
that if women show their arms somehow it
has to with sex these people are in the
gutter all the [ __ ] time
I I I cannot tell you
a single time that I can remember or
where I saw a woman without sleeves on
and because she didn't have sleeves on I
got all hopped up and horny and it made
me distracted or some [ __ ] what in the
[ __ ] are these people talking about
Jesus Christ you goddamn Republican
predators
you people are [ __ ] weirdos
it's it's it's getting out of hand it
really is
and it doesn't just stop there in the
Missouri house I mean that's a
ridiculous thing that women can't wear a
[ __ ] sleeveless shirt or something
because it's too distracting
the male members oh my God all the blood
are rushed to their wieners and they
won't be able to think and they won't be
able to they won't be able to bang up
your democracy because all the blood
will be rushed to their penis because
women don't have sleeves on Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
you know what I say I think what should
happen
what I think should happen
the best protest of all is all these
women in the Missouri legislator now
they put on string bikinis go on the
floor and stream bikinis [ __ ] them [ __ ]
them what are they gonna do [ __ ] they
gonna do be body positive about it too
straight out there with confidence yeah
really give them a [ __ ] show show
them show them what are inappropriate
dress on a house floor can look like
that's what I see yeah [ __ ] lean into it
piss on them protest like a [ __ ]
that's what I say
I don't know it's just me
oh
whoosh they're worried about they're
worried about sleeveless attire in
Missouri
[ __ ] are gonna lose track of
their budget in Missouri because they're
about to cut more taxes
on the rich in Missouri yeah that's what
they're gonna do they're going to try to
cut more taxes which is going to lower
Revenue in Missouri and Missouri just
like any other state has to balance
their budget it's part of the I don't
know state constitution
so you know what they're gonna do
redistribute the wealth to the to the
rich
in tax dollars
and tax cuts to make sure that your
students in the state of Missouri if you
live in Missouri don't have buses to
their schools that's the first [ __ ]
thing they get
that's the first I'm telling you that's
a verse doubt me you go look any [ __ ]
Governor anywhere when they have to
bounce they have to balance the [ __ ]
budget in Missouri they do not get to
borrow money
in Missouri that is not a thing and it's
against the state constitution Most
states are like that
but in the state of Missouri the first
thing they cut is public school
transportation I am not [ __ ] you
first thing they could ah nope you don't
get buses and kids don't need to go to
school anyways hey walk hey parents can
take them yeah [ __ ] it that's the first
thing they cut
because that's the way they figured ah
you know these parents will get them to
school I'm my my spouse takes my
children to school I mean
you know
why can't everyone else yeah and some
people work three jobs you [ __ ] idiot
some people are single parents
some people have four kids at three
different schools you stupid bastard
that start at three different times this
is really stupid stuff I mean it's hard
to explain reality
the people who live in delusion but you
know
that's first thing they'll cut Missouri
when they cut taxes they're going to cut
the bus transportation to schools the
second thing they've got is Highway
funding
so not only well I mean you know it
makes sense you ain't got any buses on
the road so what do you need highways
for
makes sense well the [ __ ] you don't need
good highways when there's no buses I
mean we're gonna take away your buses so
you don't need good highways
this is how these [ __ ] people think
all to make sure that a few people in
the state I don't have to pay taxes and
not that they don't have to pay taxes
they just they they want them to pay
less
it's not that they're going to force and
people are trying to force them to pay
more no what there's no one saying pay
more taxes in the state of Missouri not
one [ __ ] not one [ __ ]
not one politician is fighting for rich
people to pay more taxes in Missouri
they're all Republicans they own the
[ __ ] place
because people are voting against their
own interest
and they're concerned
they're concerned right now in the state
legislator
on how long the sleeves are on women's
attire
and you want these people in charge of
your economy oh my God that's the people
you want in charge of [ __ ]
that their number one agenda item and
their number one concern is what women
are wearing
are you serious
this is who you want in charge of
anything get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] okay let's go to some
videotape I told you I was gonna show
you this video
uh of this kid but let's go first to um
speaking of deadbeats and idiots who
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
uh I don't know this is the Speaker of
the House
and if you uh look at his attire here it
doesn't seem to be to any kind of dress
code by the way not that I give a [ __ ] I
could care less if Kevin McCarthy came
in in a sweatsuit I'm just saying
Republicans seem really [ __ ]
concerned about what women are wearing
but this dude can't even get in a suit
and tie but this is Kevin McCarthy
talking about George Santos being on
committees he doesn't have a problem
with it why would he George Santos is
just any other average lying Republican
so of course he'd be on committees let's
listen
um yeah we will be done with um
all committees and then he'll get so you
don't commit his years you said
yesterday
you raised concerns during the campaign
season well I raise cons my staff raised
concerns when he had a staff member who
impersonated my chief of staff and that
individual was let go and when Mr Santos
found out about it oh well great well
great we let the one fraud go oh yeah we
let one fraudio it's a staffer you know
he's not an elected member of Congress
that can give me a vote so that
staffer's gun he's a fraud but he can't
help me so [ __ ] him but Santos ah
committees all around committees all
around why not
um
I'm still trying to see if I'm going to
get this guest on
still working here sorry
um here's another uh
Great Clip oh my God
more anti-semitism
and the George Soros talk I get this a
lot we get this a lot in gummins oh
you're paid you're paid by Soros I don't
I I have never received a check from
George Soros
and I'm starting to wonder if I should
call the hotline
the antifa hotline
because I haven't received my check yet
but here is [ __ ] Jill Rogan and I
don't know who this [ __ ] idiot is I
have no idea maybe if Gabe Sanchez joins
us here soon he can tell me who this
dumb [ __ ] is this is Joe Rogan having
some other some Nut Job
on his show and they're talking about
George Soros
and and it's and just listen how old is
George Soros it's a good question yeah
is he he's like a vampire I had a
conversation with the governor of Texas
about him but with Greg Abbott where he
was explaining to me what George Soros
does and it's okay right there right
there right there right off the top Joe
Rogan
his Talk number one Joe Rogan is talking
to the the governor of the state of
Texas they're just having any old
conversation right this is not a good
idea
I mean I sh I I'm I am the rodeo clown
of the left okay I recognize this I know
this I know that I'm put here to
distract and to create a narrative and
help you create messaging to go out
there and win for democracy I get it I
understand my role I should not be
advising or talking to the president of
the United States no matter who the [ __ ]
it is
and it's not what I should be doing
it's not a thing
okay well it looks like we are going to
have a guest but here's the thing here's
the thing
as soon as he says Greg Abbott explains
something to me
um that's that's all you need to know
that everything after that
everything after that is complete and
utter [ __ ] all of it
the entirety of it
I don't know why we have to explain this
but you know
we do I'm trying to get my guest here
there we go okay
let's play some more of this clip it's
[ __ ] terrifying that he donates money
to a very Progressive very leftist uh
whether it's a D.A or whatever
politician and then fund someone who's
even further left than them to go
against them and just keeps moving it
along so he's playing like a global game
okay this is this is uh more of a George
Soros an anti-Semitism and Jewish cabal
and they're dancing around it instead of
being overt about it like Kanye and Nick
Fuentes were where they got in trouble
went going on their National [ __ ]
tour of Nazism and this is Joe Rogan
dancing around that right
he's like oh yeah they're they're
manipulating the system so it's more far
left and more communist and more for the
cabal and it's [ __ ] absolute lies
11 million people are listening to this
[ __ ] why aren't listen if if we could
get 11 million people to listen to this
show and I I don't think that's outside
the realm of possibility I really think
we can get 11 million people listen to
this show every single day
two hours every single day 11 million I
think we can do it
I think it's possible
they would actually get some [ __ ]
information that they could go out there
and use and it wouldn't be absolutely
just [ __ ] dribble
this is dribble this guy is a know
nothing
Joe Rogan has a purpose in life
it's to tell jokes not for people to
take him seriously especially 11 million
[ __ ] yeah and then he he enjoys
doing it yeah he enjoys doing it um but
it is
it's telling right he understood early
on where you wanted to seize power right
and and that's you know we sometimes
think oh I'm gonna you know you know a
senator is that that's the Pinnacle of
success well it's not really you know
it's the it's the DA's and it's the it's
the state level politicians right that's
where a real change occurs and where
things can happen and before you know it
it's like what the [ __ ] for real
corrosion or real corrosion right oh my
God okay I can't take it anymore again
these two guys two chuckleheads they
obviously don't understand however our
system of government works they don't
understand uh why why Democrats
Democrats want to take money out of
politics they don't understand it now
that's not the world we live in we do
not live in that world yet
and it's going to be a long time coming
if we don't fight for this democracy
there's no way we're going to be able to
take
private finance and private funding out
of our public campaigns
but that's what they're talking about
they're talking as if they're talking as
if the actual corruption
of public campaigns is only only on the
left as if the right wing isn't [ __ ]
mired in [ __ ] public corruption uh
private funding corruption in public
campaigns I'm telling you this January
6th case that Jack Smith has I don't
know if you heard about the Super Pac
and the election fund and the legal
defense fund that Trump and his allies
fleece from his supporters and stole
that money and defrauded them but that's
going to be a big tenement in this
indictment if when we get one
and it's not republi it's not Democrats
it did it's the Republicans Democrats
are trying to fight to decouple private
funding from public campaigns but we
can't do that if we don't fight the
fight we have
we can't do that unless we fight the
fight we have and that's why I have this
guest with me I'm so glad to have her
here on a Tuesday as Gabe Sanchez joins
us of all things God damn perfect timing
we got Gabe Sanchez we got Dr Rachel
bidacopper with us now Gabe Dr Rachel
bidikoffer happy Tuesday happy Tuesday
it is a good one
[Music]
yeah so we usually have Texas Paul on
Tuesday I like their heads
oh no that's okay hey it happens dogs
dogs happen
um so so Rachel oh she's gonna go deal
with the dogs yeah she's gonna let the
dogs out who let the dogs out so when we
finally got the answer well it ran Dr
Rachel bittickover Let the Dogs Out
who let the dogs in Dr Rachel bitcover
the reason why I wanted to have you on
today is because there is a big fight in
messaging on this debt ceiling thing and
um a lot of people are getting it wrong
most people are getting it right I feel
like the White House has a good stance I
feel like the house Democrats have a
good stance here and that's let them
fail what let Republicans fail in this
fight when they're trying to strip away
the benefits that the American people
have paid for because that's really what
they want they don't give a damn about
the debt ceiling they don't care about
the credit rating they want to make sure
that they do deep cuts into your Social
Security your Medicare the things that
you pay for not entitlements these are
things that you paid for tell us how we
can form a messaging and a narrative
around this because that's how we win
this fight over the next few months with
the debt ceiling is with the national
narrative to pressure these Republicans
to understand you're not going to take
away our [ __ ] and give the Democrats the
clout to stand firm and say no we're not
going to negotiate with terrorists
yeah listen if I had it my way the
entire Democratic comes work it would be
focused on this right now and what I
want them to be doing is I want them to
be on the attack I want them to be
making it perfectly [ __ ] clear What's
Happening Here the map the majority the
Republican majority of the house is
going to hold the American economy
hostage what would us right individuals
um everyone who owns a business
everybody who is in the military
everybody I mean just everybody right
you have a 401k and it's an active
economic terrorism what they're trying
to do is say my way or I'll kill you all
right and we have to make it very very
clear what's at stake here because it it
number one they were able to do this
debt ceiling stuff kind of this economic
terrorism back in 2013.
um and get away with it to some degree
because we were not aggressive enough
about pushing it on them I remember so
you know all the smart analysts other
than myself absolutely confident oh the
Republicans forced a government down you
know that's gonna Define 2014 for us
everyone's just going to magically know
that the Republicans are dysfunctional
and I am here to tell anyone that can
hear my voice right now that is not the
case if you want people to understand
that Washington DC's chaos this week is
because of Republicans and what their
goal is to steal your retirement not you
don't even need to say social security
Medicare you're saying they're coming
for your retirement right
um then we really we're going to be in
in a world of hurt so we on our side
need to stay Mission focused and make
sure our comms is is achieving one I
think overall strategic goal and that is
to point blind we got to make sure that
people see what they're doing and that
they blame them for it
Gabe Sanchez I know you probably have
some feelings on um this debt ceiling
fight because we do this stupid thing
over and over and over again and the
only reason why we do it is because
there's a party of obstruction there's a
party of no there's a party who who who
their base fundamentally doesn't
understand how our government works and
how Appropriations work and that this is
this is not money new money this is
money that even Republicans under Trump
appropriated that has to be paid the
executive branch just writes the checks
Congress appropriates them
um so Gabe I know you're frustrated with
the stupidity but tell us your thoughts
on the this debt yeah I mean like ever
since the first day that you know after
that everyone got sworn in they started
the next week it was immediately going
into oh we're gonna you know we are the
fiscal conservatives and we are going to
fix up this budget and we're going to
balance it out but really what they
started from the very beginning was
let's cut these you know these costs are
this funding to the IRS uh will
inevitably according to the CBO add 114
billion dollars by cutting 80 billion
dollars I mean these people are not good
at math and they have no sense of a a
proper Outlook I mean like because a lot
of the a lot of the efforts they make
when it comes to you know
raising the debt ceiling right holding
it hostage they don't care about
Americans they don't care what the
outcome is for them because to to
Republicans right they they got their
bag right they got their money they got
their position they have their power
they have their influence they don't
care about constituents they don't care
about voters they don't care about the
actual people who will be impacted by
this and the fact that their show just
haphazardly willing to hold this hostage
and hold it over here and say okay well
if you want us to fix it then you gotta
you you gotta meet us or really you have
to Cave into our demands and the fact
that they are so willing to do that
shows you I mean we aren't even one
month and we're we're I mean 14 days in
essentially now I mean obviously some
days after when the vote took place but
we're two weeks into this 118th Congress
because they're not even a congress
right it's a clown circus it's a chaos
caucus these people do not care and
they're willing to do whatever they can
to to get what I mean they're
essentially you know know they're
they're
they're not serious people they're not
but they're using the debt ceiling as a
ransom note right so so let me ask you
yeah let me ask doc here because Gabe's
right but what is their goal here what I
mean obviously obviously some of these
members of Congress are smart enough to
know what the ramifications of not
raising the debt ceiling could be some
of them probably not they're just so
mind [ __ ] and deluded by Q Anon that
they have no clue all they can see is
Hunter Biden's lamped up in front of
them and destroying our democracy but
what really is their goal here what is
their end goal here Rachel bidikov or
what's their political play You're the
political strategist what's their
strategy or do they have any really
I mean there is no strategy guys you
have to understand we're not talking
about a house Republican majority that
is any point of comparison to our
history right so like you know the
strategy insofar as there is one is
there's two by furricated strategies
that work quite against each other I
mean McCarthy and the so-called moderate
house debt uh House Republicans want to
you know don't keep keep out of chaos
headlines down to a minimum why they got
our economy into our [ __ ] they don't
want it to be in the main like stage
right of the show they had to do things
discreetly so
you know this is a real problem for
McCarthy because he's got he is he's the
first speaker in the entire history of
the house who is not emboldened to the
front line majority making members that
made him the speaker by giving them more
than 218 seats okay like this that's
usually who the speaker serves so when
you look at the behavior of Nancy Pelosi
or John Boehner or Paul Ryan or uh tippo
and you are all the way back you know
whatever you just pulling any speaker
out you're gonna find out that their
behavior is structured about you know
stuffing extremism so that the policy
agenda of the party that the public sees
seems pragmatic
and helpful right and McCarthy does not
have that option so he the reason they
wanted and took the speaker about 15
rounds is precisely to put him in this
position and you know I would never want
a fake position where I have no power
and I have all the baggage and title
because people are going to assume that
Kevin McCarthy has the power to govern
the house okay and instead what he did
is he traded away that power he has
absolutely no ability to keep Magda from
revolting against him if he tries to
form a bipartisan coalition to pass this
debt ceiling debate um um raise and you
know I have to tell you that there's a
big chunk of the Republican party that
is going to be terrified of defaulting
on the debt I mean their their entire
constituency and major donor base are
the people who are going to lose the
most money if the debt ceiling is
defaulted I mean it's not just about a
rank and file and the effects of veteran
benefits and SSI and Medicare and all
these other things all ultimately the
the old bread and butter of the Geo
instill the bread and butter of the
giovas money machine is the business
conservative okay and McCarthy is going
to either I either have to [ __ ] over the
business Community this week or he's
gonna have to [ __ ] over matter and
either way there will be held ahead
well I think that's the Rock and the
hard spot that Kevin McCarthy has been
in the whole time and that's why like
you said he's had trouble uh and had
trouble becoming speaker even but you
know Kevin McCarthy's a very shallow
individual
um his main goal was to have his name on
the door and to have the office and to
have the title and nothing more he
didn't actually he didn't actually care
about um governing he doesn't care about
the operation of the House of
Representatives he doesn't care about
our government the people's government
because we are the government and we
sent them there to govern he didn't care
about that he only cares about in the
history books he'll be known as a
speaker of the house no matter how long
or how short he uh is in that position
that's why he traded away the entire
thing
but in saying that and saying that I
guess the prediction is
if Democrats hold strong at the
administration holds strong it doesn't
do any negotiating with terrorists here
and tells them you either raise the debt
ceiling or you don't one or the others
I've seen this in some of the NBC and
other reports is we aren't making it
really clear
what habit is demanding the White House
give them would steal your Social
Security right so it is a non you cannot
answer this demand it's not that the
Democrats don't want to negotiate aren't
willing to negotiate [ __ ] you know we're
a party of negotiators the problem is
what Maga is saying is we want to
to
um move Social Security out of out of uh
mandatory spending into discretionary we
want to raise the retirement age because
according to white-collar Republicans
with cushy Congressional jobs people
want to work for [ __ ] ever okay well
he obviously has never met any of the
broken working class and I hang out with
because I can promise you this their
bodies cannot work forever in fact many
of them are working through incredible
pain all day every day in their 40s okay
so
um you know it's obviously he's never
met a [ __ ] working class construction
worker of his entire life if he thinks
people want to work until they're 70.
it's such a white collared bubble to say
that uh that it it really is offensive
in my opinion but um ultimately we have
to be really careful we don't do their
work for them we they are not coming to
a negotiating table they have taken the
economy hostage and they're making
terroristic demands that require us to
screw over generations of America and
for retirement
hey you know we're looking for a clip
here of the exact thing that you're
talking about uh I forget the I forget
the scumbag's name of course he's a
republican uh and he's an old white ball
sack as I like to call him uh and I
forget his name so he's just some
generic old white ball sack Republican
who was walking through the halls of the
house and um
and someone asked him about raising the
retirement age and if Gabe finds it here
then we'll play it yeah he says
something like
oh I get people come up to me all the
time and say they want to work forever
like I I I've had four people in the
last 20 years say I want to work forever
which just to be clear no matter what
the retirement age is the statute of the
retirement age is for you to receive the
benefit that you paid for called Social
Security or Medicare uh that statute
that statute doesn't dictate how long
you can work like you can work day
you're in your 90s you know nothing
stopping these people from working past
that retirement age the only thing that
the government is saying we as the
government are saying is hey you worked
long enough you paid into this system we
should give you reprieve and give you
retirement and let you enjoy the work
that you gave our country in the service
that you did for our country by working
and being a hard-working person and
paying your taxes I don't understand
where we lost our way in America with
this
um but this this representative in
particular just absolutely does exactly
what you're saying just like yeah people
want to work till other 90 anyways so we
should force them to right yeah I mean
it
comes from their bubble because they I
mean honest to God
there is a sub
70 when I get to SSI age I'll be like oh
[ __ ] if I draw my retirement it affects
your income okay it can impact your
income and so people play or whatever
their retirement enhance their benefit
size and to prevent penalties like that
but you do not design a public policy
especially like Social Security around
the exceptions okay you you design it
around the average person and the
average person is going to be broken as
[ __ ] at age age 65 and look and Counting
the damn days
to the days that they can draw that SSI
I'm in my 30s and I can't wait to retire
Rachel I mean come on who doesn't want
to he doesn't want to run
Escape it's not a arduous job I'm not
out there [ __ ] you know doing
landscaping right and there's no way I
could do that stuff right now so it
really is personal to me I um I think
that people especially in our world
don't appreciate the right the reality
the physical and health-wise realities
of the lower classes in this country and
and it just goes to show by the
Republicans insisting we all want to
work toward 90.
well and it's crazy to me that these are
the same people that have cushy have the
cushy retirements from serving a few
terms in Congress
um here's the actual clip of this uh
Mike I said white white nut sack um
Republican just a generic old white ball
sack here and you know average
Republican his last name's probably
Santos or something similar let's listen
every time
you know uh that's interesting uh that
you asked that question uh people come
up to me they actually don't work
yeah see that's on the table you're
saying
if people want to work hard maybe you
need to give them an incentive to do it
okay yeah
I know I know yeah
you just take that right there
the fact that the fact that he's like oh
yeah people come up to me all the time
and say I'll take you know what I'll
take things that never happened for 500
Alex okay because that is what is that's
that is what that is right there the
fact that somebody's willing to be like
look you know I worked all my life and
you know what I'm willing to do I'm
willing to work myself into the [ __ ]
grave nobody's ever said that no one has
ever said that you don't worry you know
where he's probably getting this when he
when he because this is uh I guess his
name is Rick Allen this scumbag from
Georgia no is it Georgia Georgia yeah
yeah Rick Rick Allen of Georgia that's
and we've identified the typical generic
white ball sack here
um but here's here's the thing is that
he goes into Walmart and he sees the
little greeter at the door and he's like
well they're working till they're 90 and
what he doesn't know is the only reason
why they're standing at the door in
their 90s is because they can't afford
they can't afford [ __ ] eggs and milk
right now because these [ __ ] idiots
won't get off their asses and do their
job and raise the social security
benefit that these people earned that's
why that old dude
and Republicans are the ones like hey
you know what we should do what this
money people have paid into Social
Security and Medicare we should [ __ ]
tax
number one like one of the reasons we
don't have enough money is people are
paying tax on their social security and
coming number two that the cost of
living adjustments that Democrats have
fought for for decades and just recently
got another huge one through before we
lost control of the house those are the
only things keeping a lot of our elderly
population off the street and they are
completely marginal so one government
shut down away from another you know
triggered uh homeless crisis of our
senior our most um you know
um desperate and vulnerable community
and that I just want to give a shout out
to Social Security Works cyc put out
that clip yeah didn't catch that early
learning uh John I don't know if you
guys have met John Bowser Bowman uh
Bozeman but he uh he's involved in
Social Security works great organization
he's a good friend of mine you guys
might recognize recognize him from such
things as the bandana
oh my gosh no we appreciate it
well we appreciate his work um also
another person we appreciate the work
for is that Aaron rupar here
um he's showing us here that Fox News oh
boy you know it's been it's been many
years since they've been concerned about
the the debt Rachel all of a sudden even
comes all of a sudden they're they're
terrified of a number they just are
posting these uh Aaron says Fox News is
lining up behind the House GOP effort to
force cutting social safety net in
exchange for paying our debts so this
Rachel and and this is what I want you
to tell the audience because this is the
thing that you know better than anyone
else and this is what I love about you
and why you're my favorite political
strategist issue no National Narrows you
know messaging drives these political
wedges and that's exactly what they're
doing right now with Fox News and their
apparatus to say that the debt's gonna
kill you that you're you're going the
country's gonna die because they're
because we're going to raise the debt on
money that we already said we were going
to spend this is this is arbitrary it's
dumb it's actually something we should
probably get rid of in the Congress so
we don't have to have this stupid fight
all the time and continue to to to to
put Americans and American economy at
risk but tell us what we can do to
combat this messaging that's on the
screen because I haven't seen this since
Mitt Romney honestly I haven't seen a a
number like this uh being put up on a
Jumbotron since Mitt Romney when uh when
they were you know really concerned
about the debt back then they haven't
been concerned about the debt in quite
some time
that's because they they cause most of
that right
and you know here's the thing is like I
want to try to tell people this I'm like
listen dude when the gas prices are
[ __ ] low you got to be like damn Joe
Biden's awesome man look what he's done
for the stocks look at he's done even
though he has nothing to do with that
[ __ ] you have to credit claim it and
what I would have done the last four
years Hammer them on that match I would
have the debt Clock I would have been
counting it or alter the Trump stuff as
a tax cuts came in I'm gonna hit it
um we have to troll them over stupid
[ __ ] like that because what we're seeing
now is exactly what I expected to see
under this new house majority which is a
complete revision of history number one
all the things that they have ignored
for Donald Trump and Mada for you know
five years now they suddenly care a [ __ ]
ton about classified Intel right uh
White House visitor logs um
Family corruption uh or trading off of
you know a family name or political
connections I mean it's just and then
you here's the thing is but I always
knew they would do this and that's why I
was like we must go after them hard on
corruption on scandals on um you know
deficit [ __ ] whatever it is because as
soon as they have the power they are
absolutely going to turn around and
they're going to start messaging against
us so you know I'm a lot less worried
about it this time because there are a
lot of people who've gotten lies to the
game but I just want to concur like
conclude my appearance today on the show
that's one important thing okay don't
get into weeds don't explain how it's
debt we already paid
one [ __ ] message repeated through
everybody okay the Republican party is
holding the economy Hostage to steal
your Social Security that's it just say
that over and over and over again all
week
Dr Rachel bittickoffer with the easy
messaging and the easy narrative to
create a national stir and to make sure
that we do not lose our democracy to
these band of economic terrorists
because that's what they're trying to do
the only thing they want is to hold you
Hostage to steal your Social Security
Dr Rachel bittickoffer thanks for
joining us we appreciate you every time
you're on here
stick around everywhere go follow doc on
Twitter she'll give you a lesson every
single day she's tweeting all day about
the national message every single day
she'll give you a master class on it and
it's free to follow her on Twitter I
can't believe that app is still free
it's free it's free okay
how to beat save democracy by beating
Republicans in their own game and it is
pure [ __ ] fire guys
and it's going to take my Twitter feed
and make it uh mainstream basically so
everyone's gonna have these tools it's
all laid out really clear on how to and
what to and why to do it and I am super
super jazzed that book will come up and
I want one of the first copies I want
one of the first copies and I want to
promote here on the show and we will
push it push it push it and I I won't
charge you a nickel because I I love you
Rachel you're you're a good friend
and you're you're a friend of democracy
and a fighter in this fight so Dr Rachel
bidikoff for everyone go follow pay
attention to that to that manuscript
coming out soon uh you're going to want
to take a look at it if you love
democracy so Rachel Dr Rachel bidikoff
for everyone we'll be right back right
after these men
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
Dr Rachel bidikoffer
the expert I'm telling you
messaging narrative
it's gonna have a [ __ ] book are you
kidding me how exciting how excited are
you
Gage is about breeding Dr Rachel
whittakoffer in long form I love her
tweets so long form would be fantastic
woo
how are you today my friend man I'm
going deep in on this Solomon Pena
situation whoa whoa getting deep in on
the Terrace so tell us about it because
um I want to know more about this story
there's not enough people talking about
it and the other thing I want to get to
um because I know this might take a
minute to hop through this story yeah
um because I want to show a picture
there's a couple videos of him
um actually being arrested
um and apparently there was several
other uh raids that had happened with
this with the SWAT
um to arrest more of these people
apparently there was an informant of the
people that he hired
um they were under Federal indictment
for drug and trafficking and Firearms
traffic in charges I believe is the
story there now but I also want to get
to this video of this [ __ ] this
father or grandfather whatever it is
teaching his little uh grandson or son
probably I don't know three how to kill
human beings
it's [ __ ] gross
um they talk about groomers but Jesus
Christ
um so I want to get to that as well
because that thing's
flying around the internet and it's
going to get bigger in the next day or
two yeah on this video on it so I want
to get to that as well
um because that ultimately ultimately
that leads us to the opinion story this
domestic terrorist who ran for congress
he's an insurrectionist he was there
January 6 apparently he was posting he
was boasting about it just last the end
of last year oh man
tell us tell us what happened tell us in
a nutshell and then rewind and tell us
how he got to this point so so basically
uh
Solomon Pena is a failed wannabe New
Mexico state legislator okay so he wrote
he was an elected official or no no no
no no no no no no no no
no
not even close oh okay all right look
look this is what happened this guy
state legislator in New Mexico
uh he he lost okay just to give everyone
context when you say he was elected no
he lost bigly okay he lost he he lost
bigly very big tiny hands down huh many
people say it was the biggest loss of
all time this is what happened all right
uh he claims okay I went through a deep
dive last night I actually ended up
getting one guy to [ __ ] uh
closed down his Twitter account uh this
morning because because I sent you this
I see this story I'm like why the [ __ ]
aren't we talk we gotta talk about this
tomorrow yeah so I'll get into that in
just a quick bit uh so basically sell
them on Pena
is like all Mega Republicans okay they
live in a deep state of denial that's
the only deep state that exists is the
level of denial that they live in okay
if you go to his Twitter page it is full
of insults misogyny rate elections uh
say that again
a deep state of denial it's the only
deep state that actually exists there's
state that exists in the mega world is
the level of denial you need to tweet
that [ __ ] tweet that [ __ ] right now I
don't know what you're doing what you're
waiting on make sure you tweet that I
will do it this is I'm also giving some
people some insight into my what was
that so this is kind of what I wrote but
anyways here's here here is here's the
guy we're talking about this is his um
this is his official picture this is his
unofficial picture right so
basically uh this guy ran he lost and
when I say lost he lost by almost 4 000
votes it was like nearly 3 600 votes and
there are 687 precincts in District 14.
I went through every single one of them
yesterday and he won he lost every
single one of those so you went to the
county records department I went to the
county records looked it up and it was
not even close it was either like
uh some were 60 margins 40 margins
thirty percent like it was not even
close like I'm sure it's because he's a
sane person is the reason why he lost it
right now and from what I understand
yeah now what if I understand Miguel uh
Garcia who is the incumbent has been in
the seat for like 26 years or whatever
and I hear that he's not the best at
what he does that that's regardless of
the reason why people didn't vote for
him what it sounds like people didn't
vote for him possibly is the fact that
he's an ex-con okay he he was convicted
of 19 felonies including burglary
larceny uh contributing to a delinquency
of a minor receiving stolen property I
guess he was also uh involved in a uh a
smash and grab robberies targeting
several big box stores in 2008 and
Miguel Garcia was hoping to disqualify
him however the uh the judge that
oversaw the district judge ruled that
the state law prohibiting former felons
from holding office under certain
circumstances was unconstitutional
clearing the way for his candidacies so
he was allowed to run even though he was
convicted on 19 different charges he was
an ex-con he was a felon he served seven
years in prison
now this is where it comes for violent
crimes it sounds like for violent crimes
right and if you go to his Twitter feed
His official it doesn't have a lot of
like he's got like 200 some odd
followers on Twitter uh for the
foreseeable future you'll be able to
visit that page assuming he doesn't
delete it once he gets out of uh you
know holding right now but what's
happening is this guy is a product of
trumpism okay
this violent extremism domestic
terrorism is a is a direct
uh product of trumpism okay this guy has
denied the election results he said it
was rigged he didn't concede
um he then said oh he had a uh and
you're talking about his own election
his own election right so then he made
it then he made a tweet about Trump and
said oh looks like Trump is running in
2024. I didn't concede I'm looking at my
options he also posted a photo uh from
from the street side on January 6 and
goes here's a photo from me on January 6
before I lost my phone at a trump rally
in uh July 2021. now I want to give
people context to this July 2021 is an
important date because it's the first
person the first January 6 writer who
was sentenced to a felony charge and at
that same time at a trump rally he just
happened to conveniently lose the phone
that I don't know would have had all of
this incriminating evidence assuming he
was brought in then he posted a photo
online being like Oh here I was on
January six uh and I just happened to
lose my phone this is the one photo I
had available okay very sus very very
sus the whole thing's weird so then
let's fast forward to December and jul
and James so this is the picture that
you're talking about here right
yeah yeah so this is him he says oh this
is me on January 6th and I lost the
phone at the Trump rally
in in July 2021 make America great again
but if you lost the phone how did they
get the photo and if you only had this
one photo then I would assume they had
other photos I don't believe he actually
lost it I believe he's saying that only
because
uh of of what happened at that same time
it's just a little it is very suspect
the fact that he loses the phone at the
same time that the first person from
Tampa Bay in Florida was was sentenced
to I think eight months uh in in prison
and then he had 20 some months or
something like that in terms of
community service so there was a first
person July 2021
um all right so the other part of this
is where we come up right now
in December in in January we found out
that there were these shootings that
happened at these different local
Democratic legislators he had two state
legislators two County Commissioners
there's also another two shootings that
uh right now aren't connected so there's
a total of six shootings but four have
been connected to Pena okay now the
Albuquerque police chief Harold Medina
described Penny as The Mastermind now I
would say Mastermind is being very
generous
uh considering he's Maga but if you look
at the statements on his Twitter account
you can get an idea of of what he is
right what he stands for
um so the SWAT team came in on Monday
they arrested him
it was very kind of nice I'm sure you'll
play the video there yeah
well they let him they let him walk to
the right so they let him they you know
they want him they'll Pat him down and
they put him in the car and that was it
so
the reason this is so important and the
reason that we should be talking about
this and I don't I mean I think more
people are beginning to to to talk about
at least some news stations right now is
the fact that again this is a direct
result of trumpism domestic terrorists
and people who don't like the outcome of
a free and and fair election they say it
was rigged I didn't get the results I
wanted it was against me I'm the victim
you stole it this and that right you
want to complain complain complain and
when you don't get the results and he
even visited the homes
of these people before these some of
these shootings even happened okay and
it turns out that this person that you
brought up uh I believe his name is Jose
true true uh
I think I think he's the one that's
flipped on these right so uh one of the
four men that penny is accused of hiring
is Jose Trujillo uh and he's being
prosecuted federally on drug trafficking
and Firearm charges so you know only the
best people
but I think he might be the person that
flipped on him
um but what we see here is what we see
here is that we have Maga committing
violence against people that either won
their seat or denied him the possibility
of challenging a free and fair election
because he and again he lost by over 3
600 votes and 687 precincts in District
14. right not a question
look if you go to the page you literally
scroll through it's just lost lost lost
the dude is a big time loser just like
Trump
and also seems to be a pattern yeah and
so basically what I just want to say is
the reason it's so important is because
this guy is you know on his knees hands
going and loving to to really take a
take a nibble on that Cheeto that that
that Cheeto that Trump offers right and
it's it is the fact that this is we have
an x-con running for office
who supports Trump doesn't accept the
outcome of the election and as a result
goes out and at one of the shootings and
this is the part that really kind of
pisses me off one of the shootings he
was actually there okay this
representative uh representative Linda
Lopez Mexico with more on this he was
there on January 3rd and the reason this
pisses me off is because when they fired
into the house right and I don't know if
this was intimidation or if he wanted
something else doesn't even [ __ ]
matter the fact that he executed this
actual you know hiring of people and did
it the the thing that pisses me off is
that three of the bullets
at representative Linda Lopez's home
went into her daughter's bedroom while
she was sleeping she's a 10 year old
girl
there's nothing to do with this election
yeah three three bullets go well I mean
like wow wait wait wait wait wait wait
you're telling me the save the children
grab the same people who are playing
bullets into the child's bedroom
seems seems weird seems weird that they
would want to save the children but kill
them with bullets flinging them into
their bedroom because they're I'll be
doing uh uh I have a lot of other what
was that running but I was like I feel
like I got to get this one in before so
I'm currently working on that what was
that
here is um here's a little bit of a news
report I think this is from a local news
station there in Albuquerque as opposed
to the National yeah this is outside the
police station where he's being held
yeah and I I believe it's News 13 here
and I believe uh they're going to play a
bit of the press Catherines from law
enforcement let's listen
just a few hours ago a SWAT team
arrested former GOP candidate Solomon
Pena at an apartment complex near Cole
and Tingley they believe these shootings
were politically motivated
shootings were orchestrated they were
dangerous attacks not only to these
individuals which is personally the most
terrifying for them but fundamentally I
I apologize this is the mayor
um not law enforcement but the mayor is
is yeah the same same place where the
where the chief also spoke right um
right but usually the mayor is the the
boss of the police department and and
this raid was done by the police of City
of Albuquerque so let's listen we also
to democracy that is why this is so
terrible
this type of radicalism is a threat to
our nation and it has made its way to
our doorstep right here in Albuquerque
New Mexico
Solomon Pena was taken into custody at a
downtown apartment building this
afternoon Pena made headlines last year
as a convicted felon running as the
Republican candidate for the New Mexico
house district 14. Pena serves five
years in prison for leading a burglary
ring at the time Pena said he got a
degree and turned his life around Pena
lost his race to incumbents
representative Miguel Garcia but never
conceded APD says today after the
election Pena showed up uninvited at the
homes of county commissioner Adrian
barboa former commissioner Debbie
O'Malley and state senator Linda Lopez
handing them documents that he claimed
proved there was fraud in the election
results APD says pena committed one of
the shootings himself but hired other
people to pull the trigger on his behalf
in other shootings
after the election in November Solomon
pinch and here we'll see from the deputy
commander of the Albuquerque Police
Department so yeah reached out and
contracted someone uh for a amount of
cash money to commit at least two of
these shootings the addresses of these
shootings were communicated over phone
within hours in one case the shooting
took place
the home of democratic house Speaker
Javier Martinez was also shot at in
early December APD announced last week
they made an arrest in connection to one
of the shootings APD saying today that
man Jose Trujillo is one of the hired
Hitmen back to you is that the same
person uh that's the one that I said was
on drug trafficking and right and it
seems like probably they have they
flipped I would imagine if you already
are in being investigated for uh drug
trafficking and Firearm charges like
you've already got ATF on your ass right
you're probably gonna probably gonna
flip well right I mean you're looking
for a deal especially if they got good
evidence on another case
um let me ask you
um have they formally charged pinyin
when have they formally charged him with
and who has charged him is it the state
or the Feds that have charged him uh
that's a good question I don't know if I
let me see if I can get an updated uh
because I'm sure I don't know if they
they actually announced charges
yesterday or their way I mean
they arrested him right because at least
last night it was
right don't have to charge him a bench
yeah you don't have to do it and they're
gonna I mean obviously they're gonna you
know they're gonna cover up and there'll
be bail hearings and that's right and
I'm not sure what the bail wall is in
them right in New Mexico but
I haven't seen anything that he was
charged with I do see just arrested
alleged you know he was in connection
with right
um
yeah so again how this I I want to show
you used so I want to show you how
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] is right right now
if in our narrative trending on Twitter
and Let me refresh this just to be sure
training on Twitter uh number one right
now is Kid Rock right now the biggest
news story right now in this country is
this [ __ ] political violence story
where this Pena not only not only shot
at one but hire people to shoot at
multiple buildings yeah he's going to
intimidate officials yeah with with what
could only be probably fraudulent
documents or [ __ ] that he made up like
he's there is one person he visited and
I believe the person who actually lived
there or lives there but they told him
they didn't and there's a video of him
which I'll get for the the what was that
but basically he shows up and there's a
ring there's a ring doorbell video he
goes up asking for this woman and he
says oh does so and so live here and
they're like I don't know know if they
recognized who he was or they're like I
don't know who you are so I'm not going
to say that they live here you know and
they're like oh uh they they don't live
here anymore
and he's like oh do you know where they
live and the woman was like oh yeah they
live around the corner at blank blank
blank blank and I don't know if they
actually gave the address it was bleeped
out
um so whether or not that person lives
there or not but the video is from the
person that he was going there to look
for so my assumption is
she actually does live there and he gave
her or she gave him like a [ __ ]
address around the corner kind of thing
for him to go look but the fact that
he's showing up at people's houses
pissed off and upset butt hurt and
triggered a [ __ ] snowflake that
didn't get what he wanted because this
guy is an absolute idiot I mean also
keep in mind that the district that they
ran in has has like 75 percent of the
time always been Democrats so it wasn't
going to flip anytime soon it wasn't
gonna happen he didn't have a good
chance he didn't have any chance I mean
again if you were to go look through the
county records it's literally like 20 to
80 30 to 70. uh 25 to 75 I think the
total end result was like 76 to 24
something like that that was the outcome
that he lost by 50 is is like the margin
there that he lost at the end result the
guy lost bigly and he got mad and this
is what we have to be careful of like we
we need to obviously mock these people
like I'm gonna [ __ ] mock the [ __ ] out
of this guy but also need to take it
seriously because these people the more
and more especially as we have Trump
running in 2024 especially as as we have
him attacking Jack Smith special counsel
Jack Smith especially as we have him
you know uh continue to say that the
election was rigged by instilling that
that argument or that narrative in
maga's mind these trump-hopping
Republicans they're going to continue to
say anything that they go in for
election or anything any outcome that
[ __ ] don't get a job they want
they're gonna say it was rigged right
they're going to say it wasn't fair
they're going to say that they don't
like them all of this [ __ ] and so we're
going to see more and more of this right
uh people hiring you know [ __ ] random
people hired hits whatever it might be
and and National national attention has
even give way for these people locally
to do these things like Kerry Lake right
like she's refused who says supposedly
she's now going to run for Senate
against how how the [ __ ] is that if
she's the governor I don't know all I
know is I'm willing to watch that trash
fight
go go out in real time if she wants to
fight her go so be it Christian Cinema
[ __ ] it go run independent run
independent Carrie Lake can run on the
crazy ticket and whoever we put up as a
Democrat can sail through
um there's plenty plenty of good
candidates in Arizona uh to hold that
senate seat
um and and in place of Christian Cinemas
craziness and Carrie Lakes definitely
yeah oh he oh this guy uh the Solomon
Pena was also a big fan of uh Mark
fincham surprise price
Mark fincham is the uh the guy ran for
Secretary of State who was going to
absolutely just undermine the Arizona
Constitution right he was the one who
had 2011 yeah he had clear evidence like
Rudy Giuliani had clear evidence that
there was voter Frost
and even on 60 Minutes when Anderson
Cooper was like oh you got the proof and
he's like oh well we have the proof and
they're like can you show it he's like
well I can't and my ass my ass you
[ __ ] lying sex of [ __ ] uh and Mike
Mike fincham wants to stoke uh
stochastic terrorism and now we're
leading into not just a stochastic
terrorism it's losing candidates are now
uh [ __ ] trying to shoot and kill
their opponents and shooting at
buildings and trying to intimidate them
at their doorsteps but here's why here's
why because uh we have Maga have you
seen this video yet of this show I saw
another video that was a dad teaching
the girls their role in the house yes
and it was a video of that's a silent
one I like the player but it's silent
yeah yeah that one I was I was like of
course of course you would try to you
know instill this misogynistic uh uh
patriarchy man is the best and the woman
just does the dishes and the choice type
[ __ ] one of the one of the parts of
that video where the dad is uh they're
grooming the little girls
um to to be part of the what what's the
show
um handmaid's tale is that what it's
called oh handmade steel yeah yeah to be
one uh to be like that one part in the
video is the dad takes off his shoes now
now there's no
um sound to the video they just have
words up on the on the screen but he
takes off his shoes and he he flows
throws back the Lazy Boy and the little
girl is expected to come over and grab
his shoes and put his shoes away as if
he's I mean you know we get into this
Alpha Beta stuff if you're such an alpha
you have to have a little girl put away
your shoes you are such a [ __ ] weak
piece of [ __ ] and not only that but if
you're trying to like
you know Maga loves to say they're super
smart right they love to say
that they say that I don't know man
they're all well they do they do in the
comments on show but like oh like I I
can't not kill them a thousand buddy
here to tell you how how smart they are
uh and how clever they are I released a
what was that yesterday right that was a
it was a weekend round yeah it was the
it was the last week kind of Roundup
thing and I had someone who wrote U
equals not bright oh
um well I mean you know that sounds
pretty intelligent yeah I mean I'm not
alive but you know but at the same time
I'm like that's the best you could come
up with the best you that's the best
that you could absolutely come up with
and your big brained Maga
like that's what that's that's what yeah
and so I don't know man it's just our
education system has really brought us
to this to this it is why we need to
fund public education yes not only that
damn we need to fundamentally change
public education in this country here's
what I mean by that is that we do not
teach people to learn anymore we teach
people to look at the authority and the
authority that they want and believe
everything that that Authority says and
what I mean by that is on every issue
like literally why would you go would
you go to your mechanic if you were
having heart trouble Gabe Sanchez when
you go to your mechanic and be like man
I'm really having chest pain I'm
weakness of breath and I don't know what
to do and you're really smart you're
really good at like engines so can you
help me with my heart no you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't do that you would go
to the authority of the heart problem
but we don't these people are not doing
that they're not doing that at all they
don't listen to the proper Authority on
any of this well that's I don't know you
might you you might depending on who the
mechanic is yeah they could be spending
a lot of time on Twitter and other
foreign
cancer it was the vaccine it was the
vaccine right right oh you have an ache
in your toe and you can't get it to go
away definitely vaccine and you're
probably gonna Keel over and die
tomorrow because of it
um I would almost imagine that this Dad
I I guess that's what this is it looks
like he has a holster
both of them do oh that's good and it's
a real gun here so these are real guys
the kid that probably can barely hold on
to the gun and barely I mean who knows
I'm not sure how old this can recoil but
[ __ ] man this guy I mean I don't know
the person in the living room they're
they're they're in the living room he's
not reading stories now let me let me
rewind a bit before we watch this yeah
when you were a kid did you go hunting
you said you went hunting with your
grandpa right uh with my with my uncles
okay your uncles so um they probably
when you first went hunting they
probably like hey you need to hold the
rifle this way you can't point it at
people you got to make sure the Barrel's
down barrels up I mean even before that
even before that it was like all right
we're gonna go out at you know [ __ ]
way before the sun comes out we're gonna
pack you into this bright ass orange
suit right and you're just gonna sit
here and watch right right but but the
thing is you were taught certain things
about the fire yeah they're [ __ ]
dangerous right right and the thing that
you were taught about Firearms the same
thing I was taught when when and I
didn't like hunting when I was a kid
number one why do I have to kill an
animal you can drive to the store and
buy all the music you want like why
I get the population control and stuff
and the sport of it but I I never wanted
to kill a [ __ ] animal for no [ __ ]
reason other than to get my rocks off
right I just didn't understand it and it
was way too cold way too [ __ ] early
didn't want to do that [ __ ] I don't like
early don't like cold that that's not a
thing now
the one thing though that we were taught
because there were guns in our house and
we were around guns because we were real
areas most of them hunting rifles and
they weren't designed to hunt humans
really most of the gun safety Gabe
Sanchez what that I was taught was to
make sure you didn't inadvertently kill
a human yeah like that's either yourself
or like someone hunting with you like
most of the gun safety that you learn is
to not kill a human right that's most of
the gun training that you would get when
you were a child now this is usually
when you go to the gun range right and
right you know you have to follow
protocol to make sure that everyone is
safe because it's not just you right
it's also other people that are down the
line that are shooting right and most of
the time like um
um in my experience we didn't actually
go to a gun our gun range was the
[ __ ] field and we were siding in we
put at a Target and we were citing in
Scopes and stuff like that we were
taught how to sight in Scopes and that
sort of thing
um I had a I had a really nice pellet
gun now this thing was [ __ ] awesome
it was a pump pellet gun and it had CO2
and I had a great scope on it and I
would cite my scope all the time I love
that thing because I could I could shoot
all kinds of crazy old things that was
going on but but we were taught we were
taught certain gun safety to not injure
human beings right now this here
this Dad is training this little boy who
is not old enough to hold a a an actual
hunting rifle or let alone shoot one I
mean this kid does like like if we're if
we're discussing the pure physics of it
this kid doesn't I I feel like and I
don't know about this handgun but I feel
like any other gun that's possibly
larger than this handgun
would this kid would not be able to
handle the [ __ ] recoil right well
this is a this is another continuation
of there's a story in Indiana and
there's a there's a video of it you can
go out and see it I don't think we'll
watch it here today of a child walking
around in an apartment complex with a
handgun of his dads
um just casually walking around bang
bang you know
um but this this video here
shows you exactly the gun culture that
I've been yelling and screaming about
that this is new stuff folks this is new
stuff this I'm telling you this white
Christian nationalism is Terrorism they
are the American Taliban they are
Al-Qaeda this video [ __ ] proves it
because this dad thinks it's so cool
that he's teaching his little child how
to kill a human being I forgot what part
of the Bible is that in well you know
there is a book of dumb [ __ ] um yeah uh
let's let's watch this here it's [ __ ]
revolting but you have to put your eyes
on it to know that they're doing it
oh
bracket
dump it
thank you
[Music]
drop it
racket
dump it
[Music]
stop it
dump it
slow down dump it
clear
in the whole stream
[Applause]
good job
oh great job there sonny
um fantastic I mean the thing that gives
it away
the dad's like okay slow down there yeah
[ __ ] the kid is
is you know giving a gun excited to do
with his dad whatever [ __ ] father-son
grooming experience I mean again to for
full disclosure when I was a kid we were
taught how to clean guns we were talking
yeah
the idea that they're in the household
and he's like whoa slow down there like
you know but the thing is when I was
when I was a kid and and I was older
than this young little boy before they
would really let me put my hands on on
Firearms yeah
um but here's the thing because our
Firearms were rifles they were huge yeah
or or like the I think my grandpa had a
38. there was no way as a little boy
that I would be able to [ __ ] right
yeah like I I learned he was a 38
revolver right but here's the thing
is
the gun culture in this country for
decades and decades and decades it was
always focused around hunting gun safety
was always focused around making sure
not to kill other humans literally they
have switched from not making sure that
gun safety is focused around not hurting
yourself or or are your fellow hunters
or are your fellow people who are using
Firearms to we are training you how to
kill other humans yeah literally this is
mass shooter training in the living room
of this home and and the reason why it's
Mass shooter training you know a lot of
people are going to give me [ __ ] like oh
you're talking about the kid how dare
you I think someone [ __ ] commented
that [ __ ] in my thread when I said this
is mass shooter training all right said
what in the mass shooter training is
this [ __ ] yeah well here's the thing I
mean when you look at Virginia literally
a six-year-old kid brought a gun to
school shot his 25 year old teacher and
now they're in critical condition I
wonder where he learned that from oh my
gosh
don't come in the comments and be like
oh you're Dirty Nugget yeah because when
when left alone those kids are gonna
[ __ ] take a gun or with permission
gonna take the gun how else how do they
know any different than this [ __ ] box
basically training his son to kill other
human beings with a gun that he doesn't
know he doesn't even understand the
power the kid cannot even fully
understand the power that he's holding
in his hand it's not possible yeah with
his development exactly you can't expect
these kids to even to even uh cook a
meal in a kitchen without making a
complete mess you can't trust him with
slime trust me do not trust kids with
slime they'll put it down the [ __ ]
Dreams
yeah even the idea that like as as
adults we can't rent a car until we're
25 you know for various reasons but also
just like how are you know the the front
portion of our brain and how it develops
you can't tell me that a young child
especially a six-year-old kid who brings
a gun to school for whatever reason
whatever they were taught whatever
ideology was in their mind and they were
groomed with well they were upset and
they needed to fix the problem and the
best way to fix a problem my dad said in
the living room while he was teaching me
how to Rack a gun and put three Clips in
the gun so that I could kill as many
people as I possibly could when I get
mad and I have a problem and I can't
solve it with anything but a firearm
that's Mass shooter training people this
Dad is teaching his kid rather he
realizes it or not whether he's deluded
enough or not to realize he's training
his son to be a [ __ ] Mass shooter and
I would even you know and I'm gonna make
the argument here that as you know a
six-year-old kid or whatever however old
they may be as a child who brings a gun
to school let's say or even in this
household I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say that these children don't understand
what they're doing they don't understand
what they're using really right they're
in in the same way that I would say like
when you cram for a test right you're
basically just like dumping out a bunch
of regurgitated knowledge or information
on the exam to be like oh yeah it's a
it's a b cool Jude this whatever in that
same way
it becomes muscle memory you're taught
you know what it is you're explaining
what it is
but you don't understand what it is
right and that's the that is the key
difference here where you give a child a
gun they might be able to say it back do
it back do whatever you need but when
you ask them to actually understand and
explain what it is to really
fundamentally break it down and explain
each part not just hey this is
regurgitated because I've seen there's a
there's a video I think with Oprah and
she's talking to a young pastor's kid
right and she's talking about oh giving
a sermon and all this stuff and the only
way this kid knows how to give a sermon
is to [ __ ] yell okay to [ __ ] yell
as loud as he can in a super like Angry
demonic way
and she says can you explain what that
means the dad jumps in and tries to
explain and go no no no no I want to
know if he understands what he said and
he begins to try to explain it and
what's going on is the kid doesn't
really understand what he says is just
what his dad told him about what that
was in the same way this is here is you
got a kid young Whatever Gets a gun
trained muscle memory knows what to say
and how to say it back but doesn't
understand the consequences for what
they do because they only because again
you're a kid you can't control your
emotions you're very uh we'll say uh
volatile in your response and so when
you get upset and frustrated a lot of
kids throw a tantrum right they get
upset they want to get back they oh they
want to take it out on something they
don't know how to how to actually Digest
and comprehend what's going on so you
throw a gun into the [ __ ] mix of
course they're gonna shoot someone they
don't like what they said they don't
like that they're mean they don't like
that you know they lost a [ __ ]
election a free and fair election
they're gonna [ __ ] shoot people well
[ __ ] take it out on people and
they're mad about other people being who
they want to be because I saw this the
other day the biggest danger of taking
your child to a drag show is that a
Christian could show up with a gun and I
wanna I wanna I wanna end on that note
um right there I think that's a great
note to end on again the biggest danger
to taking your child to a drag show is
that a Christian like this guy who's
teaching his son how to be a mass
shooter in the living room shows up with
that gun that he's got because we also
know the last shooting well at least I'm
sure there's been other shootings of
course but the last major shooting that
we saw was at a drag show and who was
the person that saved the day the people
who were there attending and also the
actual drag queens themselves
and I I want to end on that with the uh
because um we're getting close to the
second hour here so everyone thank you
for joining us today I want to thank Dr
Rachel bittickoffer for coming in last
moment on Tuesday we don't have Texas
Paul here because he's on vacation
everyone go to Texas Paul social media
wish him a happy vacation and go to Dr
Rachel bittickoff for his social media
we're gonna I'm I'm excited about this
book now yeah I'm super excited about
this book but everyone subscribe right
here to the Tony Michaels podcast we're
trying to get to 20 000 help us help us
help us the thing that you can do is not
just subscribe you have to subscribe to
the YouTube channel but also share this
link with three other people get them to
subscribe maybe get them to get three
other people download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google
and make sure to leave us a great review
while you're there follow us on face our
excuse me on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and on Facebook at the Tony Michaels
you know the you know the routine Gabe
Sanchez same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon